yes but i do think republicans have
their degree of corruption as evidenced
by this story from timcast.com candidate
robbie starbuck responds to being kicked
off tennessee ballot starbuck told tim
cast he is exploring every legal option
to remain in the congressional race
that's right
they tried passing this law to bump him
and another individual off the ballot by
saying they didn't live there long
enough turns out robbie actually did
live in this district long enough now i
guess they're claiming he's not a
republican what robbie starbuck morgan
ortegas and baxter lee were all
disqualified from the upcoming primary
after the parties vote on april 19th
that they did not meet its standards for
bonafide republicans their candidacy was
challenged earlier this month triggering
a vote by the state election committee
according to the bylaws a candidate is
required to have voted in three of the
last four republican primaries or have
state republicans vouch for them quote
the idea that i am not a republican is
most offensive because if i am not who
the hell is starbucks said
starbuck uh he apparently said let me
see if i can find the quote that he's
been uh the 30 33 year old said he had
14 vouching letters affirming his status
as a republican including statements
from several county party chairs and the
leader of the nashville young
republicans he was also endorsed by u.s
senator rand paul in 2021 wow starbuck
largely attributed the party's vote to
institutional corruption believing that
republican leaders in the state would
prefer a controllable rhino right this
is how the the system works in order to
get into office it's through one of the
two parties
the parties are private organizations
who can do whatever they want so they
are blocking robbie starbuck from being
able to run because he's a real
candidate well and this goes to my point
so there are probably a lot of
conservatives in tennessee and we may
presume well you know tennessee that's
got to be conservative down there well
that republican party leadership has
been a long time moderate
um operation i mean the
republicans from tennessee at least in
the senate haven't been as hardcore as i
would have liked and this is why people
should participate in party politics
you know you can't you can't spit from
the outside and expect the party to
change if you're a democrat
get involved in democratic politics if
you're a republican get involved in
republican politics if you don't
that's what happens yeah i wonder if
it's also because of nashville being in
tennessee whenever you have a large
urban center like that it skews your
elections to the left and you get uh you
get
fake republicans yeah
well robbie's definitely a republican i
know the guy i've looked him in the eyes
i mean i'm kind of being facetious
well okay
but he is what you just said for people
to get into politics i cannot fathom how
to fix the system from within the system
because the system is busted it's like
being on a broken train that's about to
go off a cliff if you have the chance to
fix it from above and you can actually
see the whole train and fix the tracks
now we're talking but if you want to get
on board man how can you fix
the train and the tracks from inside
well it's the same thing about the
school board fight you can't you can't
you know you have to be at the table in
order to affect the debate and you show
up at these meetings they're usually
boring
and you just you show up at political
meetings and that you know a lot of
people don't
and if you do and you're principled you
can go far and because people need
bodies and before you know it you're the
county chair before you know it you're
on the state executive committee of the
party and before you know it you're in a
position to certify someone like robbie
starbuck onto onto a ballot or oppose uh
someone who shouldn't be on the ballot
so it works both ways and you know we
want the parties to be strong
our establishment wants the parties to
be weak
and and to kind of have a vanilla flavor
throughout the system and if you want
distinctions and you want activism you
got to learn how to win i mean that's
the
and way to do that is by participating
in the process you need activism the the
left is really good at organizing phone
call and postcard letter campaigns
what are what are republicans going to
do right now after what they're doing to
these candidates namely robbie starbuck
because this is bs
they're just lying saying he's not a
republican so that they can boot him off
the ballot well every republican needs
to figure out how to organize
every individual who believes in robbie
starbuck and is sick of the corruption
in in this machine staring in the face
of it needs to get organized and figure
out something because i'll tell you what
the left would do they wouldn't stop
calling you you'd you would get 50
leftists and they would just hit the hit
redial and then wait for the phone to
answer and then start complaining when
they hang up hit redial again and their
phones would be off the hook and just 50
people
yeah i mean each leftist has all 50 of
their personalities call in to complain
right that's right all their head mates
yeah yeah i just wanted to say before we
move on from this topic is that one of
the best ways that you can do this kind
of activism is to call your local gop
like if you're in tennessee listening to
this you should talk to the gop there in
tennessee and tell them that you're not
okay with this they're crooked people
people need to protest yeah volunteer
and you know for instance on the
election systems if you don't like the
way elections are run
go and participate in running elections
you can get hired i mean you you know
the unions you know they they're gonna
get hired they make it a point to get
higher to count votes well republicans
and conservatives should make it a point
to be hired and count votes
that's the way to ensure that elections
are more fairly run
actually count the votes well according
to the law
at the time we have a corporation
tallying
votes in private which is dominion for
the last presidential election which is
incredibly disturbing i think we need to
also in addition what you're saying tom
build a parallel system where you can
vote in their system and vote in this
system that's transparent and see if it
lines up no
yes no ian well no and you know what we
have to do
we have to free the code you're right a
big a big tech big technology firms that
are functioning in the commons their
code needs to be free this is the
freedom
we need to free the software code of the
voting machines yeah they need to be
able to reference those these companies
that are doing digital vote counting
that code needs to be public and it and
and here's what needs to happen
before the election
uh there there should be a an audit
where
a person from each you know party and an
independent
goes in with an approved you know tech
person who then
audits the code and presents it to the
public and says here's how the code of
this machine works
every single every single line is
available for public viewing i feel like
even then it could they could give you
the code and say this is how it works
but then go in the back room and make it
do other things sure
so you need it on a blockchain too
honestly i think they're bold enough
that they would show you the actual code
and if anyone pointed out any problems
with it
fact check false there is no problem
with the code it's not a conspiracy
theory no no because uh remember when
democrats were screaming there was going
to be fraud in the election like in 2019
or something they were like we got to do
something about this and then they all
started shutting up when you have
before an election and no one knows how
things are going to swing you see one
thing wrong and the democrat is going to
be like no no and the republicans will
be like no no fix it fix it we we object
because unless someone's in on it well
my view on these companies dominion and
smartmatic you know they've come up with
these outrageous lawsuits against
critics
that seem to be mighty political and
over the top
and you know we want these companies to
be neutral right and it seems to me
they've thrown down the gauntlet on one
side of the political narrative when it
comes to our elections and i would be
very suspicious whether their code works
or not
about letting them work in any states
yeah the thing that they're going after
is people
claiming that they're fraudulent i'm not
making that claim i'm claiming that i
can't see the code so i don't know if
it's fraudulent or not well i i think i
think
whether you see the code or not is
almost irrelevant to the question of
are we counting ballots in a way that
people are confident that the
individuals casting the ballots are
eligible to vote and i don't think
that's true whether if the code works
you know illegal votes
will be counted accurately but i think
that's not going to solve the problem
i'm not i'm not
the issue is so much deeper than just
i guess i suppose illegal voting because
you can track those things down but if
california opens their border up and
says come on in and then the census
happens and they're like look how many
how many more people we get and they get
more votes in the electoral college it
doesn't matter if the individual votes
all that matters is we know texas will
be blue and taxes can can effectively
stuff the electoral college ballot
by bringing in non-citizens you know the
system should be set up in a way to uh
and i think you're highlighting the
issue
to reassure people that their votes are
going to be counted and counted
accurately and the election result is
going to be something approximate to the
actual
what actually happened the winner won
whether it's exact or not the winner won
and right now
half the country doesn't think that's
the system and so we need to reassure
the public we need to save elections
by requiring voter id
maybe getting rid of the computer
counting or make it a lot more easily
watchable
and having one day only voting
only emergency
absentee voting if you're getting your
head shot off abroad and you're in the
military maybe yeah that that warrants
you getting a special treatment everyone
else show up there but the idea that
you're voting out there without any
supervision any party looking at you to
make sure you're not being intimidated
or outside the protection of the of
security and our government processes
it's an open opportunity for fraud and
when people don't have confidence in the
system the system collapses
well i'll put it this way if uh
someone invited you over to their house
in you know the middle of a big city
it's like chicago chicago's a good
example
and uh they said you can crash here
we have no doors or windows all like
they're basically just all exposed and
open
and uh no no one will like we've we've
never like you know filmed anybody
coming in here so you know we don't
think it's an issue would you be
comfortable like chilling in there and
leaving your stuff
and going to bed you're like no
i don't i'm going to keep my bag close
to them i'm going to wrap my arms around
the backpack as i go to sleep because
you'd be like i'm not okay with this
it's not an issue of whether or not
someone did or or
is in the act of committing an illegal
act it's that why would you want to
participate in an insecure system like
hey come crash at my house while you're
in chicago the doors the front door and
the back door are completely off the
hinges and the windows have all been
removed but you can sleep wherever you
want you'd be like nah i'm good or you
go to the bank and they've got black
paint over all the cameras and you give
cash to someone standing out front who
says don't worry i'll get it to the
teller and the teller doesn't keep any
records who gave it to the money and
where the money is supposed to be going
you know when you've got us you have to
have a system in place that survives
basic scrutiny it ain't going to be
perfect i mean we we were doing an
analysis of voter roll lists in new york
and california oregon
in new york i think they removed ten
names in the entire city over the last
four years they should have removed
hundreds of thousands of names so you've
got the list are full of people who have
moved away
and that's just like a big pool of
voters
to pull from illegally to engage in
fraud and that undermines the system and
and the courts have found interestingly
tim that you don't need the proof fraud
in order to justify these rules
it's the appearance of fraud and the
opportunities for fraud that states have
an interest in stopping to reassure
voters that your vote's going to be
counted so the left says you don't you
don't we don't have to prove fraud
in order to justify voter id
and to make sure that people are
actually citizens for instance before
they're allowed to vote which is to me
the
voter id everyone agrees with well it
doesn't work if uh citizen non-citizens
can get that type of voter id that
allows them to vote yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you